[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 débat les compteurs
d'électricité
linky ces petits boîtiers vers
progressivement installés dans toutes
les habitations française avait été
annoncé comme une solution à la
surconsommation d'énergie
pourtant il suscite toujours aussi
vivement la polémique
on leur a successivement reproché le
recueil de données personnelles sans
consentement
la diffusion d' onde électromagnétique
dangereuse plus récemment un rapport de
la cour des comptes évoqué un dispositif
coûteux pour le consommateur mais
avantageux pour aînés 10 est aujourd'hui
à un mois de la trêve hivernale
l'association ufc que choisir lance une
alerte sur la situation des ménages
précaires disposant d'un long compteur
linky
dorénavant ce boîtier en effet permet
aux distributeurs d'électricité de
couper ses besoins la l'électricité à
distance sont pas en discuter alors
est-ce que les compteurs linky sont un
outil utile pour réduire la consommation
et la facture d'électricité
où est-ce qu'ils desservent le
consommateur pourquoi est ce que ces
voitures et font toujours polémique
c'est le débat du jour alors on se sur
ce plateau ce soir point parle avec nous
tout marc bourdeau directeur territorial
des yvelines des yvelines chez est née
10 et puis guy rossignol vice président
du fc que choisir à versailles
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être
avec nous pour cette fuite débat alors
avant d'en parler je vous propose de
regarder ce micro trottoir dans lequel
nous avons recueilli l'avis des yvelines
noir sur ces nouveaux compteurs linky
j'ai pas m'en plaindre moi j'en ai chez
moi donc j'ai pas j'ai pas mon plan je
suis content parce que je sais pas à
quoi ça sert et d'autant plus qu'ils
nous obligent à le faire ces pratiques
il pas besoin de se déplacer nous
d'ériger un lien et l'installent ya plus
besoin qu'un technicien viennent avec
les compteurs linky semble
contre le compteur linky d'abord comme
13 autres pays européens inutile de
déployer ses ne pas intéressant et ça
gêne énormément les utilisateurs dans
leur vie privée et ça coûte pour ça fait
des économies d'énergie leur histoire a
priori je plutôt contre ouais je pense
que ça envoie des ondes qu'on n'a pas
besoin de ça il y en a déjà suffisamment
en ville je crois que ce soit de
compteurs qui sont très très performant
et ça nous permet un peu de voir notre
consommation régulière par rapport aux
anciennes contre un terrain puisque les
anciens compteurs voilà donc pour ce
micro trottoir des pour et des contres
alors première question je vous posais
qui signale qu est ce que reproche
exactement les associations de
consommateurs et quelles solutions
vous proposez bien les associations de
consommateurs ont été associés à ses
taux au déploiement de linky particulier
en ile-de-france en ce qui me concerne
dès janvier 2016
et donc on nous a présenté ce compteur
comme un conteur verts qui remplace un
compteur bleu qui aurait pas de coût
supplémentaire pour les consommateurs
que n'y aurait pas d'impact sur les
installations internes et c'est donc et
donc il n'y avait pas de problème ni de
preuves de d'ondés électromagnétiques ni
de deux problèmes liés au transfert des
données
bon donc on a écouté des discours
ensuite en tant qu association locale on
a commencé à recevoir un certain nombre
de consommateurs qui nous ont dit que il
avait des problèmes chez eux après à la
suite de l'installation du compteur des
équipements électroménagers qui ne
fonctionnait plus
il ya eu le rapport de la cour des
comptes qui a expliqué qu' effectivement
finalement ça n'était pas si gratuite ça
puisqu'il est probablement opéré plus
tard après le déploiement et puis il ya
un certain nombre de promesses qui
avaient été tenues notamment de fournir
ou ménages les plus précaires des des
petits appareils pour mesurer leur
consommation en euros et non pas en
kilowattheures parce qu'il permet pour
ces ménages de maîtriser leur
consommation
et puis avait apparemment pour des
problèmes purement administratif
ces afficheurs ne sont pas déployés ils
ne seront peut-être jamais s'en rend
compte et oui les problèmes de coupures
à distance qui sont tout à fait possible
maintenant avec cette technologie
mais pour lesquelles bon il ya eu aussi
des promesses de de dialoguer avec les
consommateurs encore concernés on est
très inquiet ce niveau là d'accord il me
semble deux appels du fc là dessus et le
plus récent concerne c'est l'inquiétude
sur les ménages les plus précaires qui
risque de se voir couper l'électricité
en cas de non payées à distance ce qui
est inédit puisqu'à auparavant un
technicien devait intervenir vous
répondez quoi à cette inquiétude alors
déjà peut-être en introduction
repréciser comment se passe le
déploiement du compteur linky je vais
répondre à votre question
l'installation des compteurs dans les
yvelines se passe très bien dans une
tradition on va y revenir dans le
déploiement mais il se passe très bien
on est à 40 4% aujourd'hui de
déploiement sur les yvelines donc c'est
à dire près d'un foyer sur deux est
équipé déjà du compteur linky donc le
déploiement se passe très bien on est
parfaitement sur la trajectoire et on
pourra y revenir si vous voulez aborder
plus de détails sur la partie coupure à
distance il faut bien comprendre
qu'aujourd'hui nous ne changeons rien
dans les procédures qui sont de la
coupure je rappelle pour impayés c'est
bien de ça qu'on parle à nos clients qui
ne payerait pas à sa facture
d'électricité à son fournisseur le
fournisseur nous envoie une demande de
coupure et on ne change absolument rien
avant le compteur linky ou après le
compteur linky à notre procédure notre
procédure est la suivante nous prévenons
systématiquement le client avancé
coupure d'accord ça vous le garantis ces
garanties les questions là continuent à
le faire comme on le faisait auparavant
la différence avec linky c'est que oui
la coupure peut intervenir à distance
donc on prévient le client que la
coupure va potentiellement avoir lieu on
se laisse un délai de 48 heures pendant
ces 48 heures il peut éventuellement
régulariser sa facture payée une partie
de sa facturation fournisseurs à ce
moment là on ne coupe pas le courant
voilà comment sa différence
l'intervention physique
alors il me semble que vous vous
préconisiez des compteurs pour les
ménages précaires je vous laisse
s'épanouir ont préconisé d'ailleurs
c'est inscrit dans la loi sur la
transition énergétique il était prévu
que la fourniture de petit afficheur
qu'on peut appeler des consos m c'est
d'ailleurs c'est disponible dans le
commerce mais à un prix de 40 à 50 euros
ils ne trompent pas ces appareils
permettent donc de maîtriser la
consommation en europe alors que le
compteur louis en lui-même n'affiche que
des kilowatts d'accord c'est leur terre
c'est ça devait être installé 2 au 1er
janvier 2018 et puis pour des raisons
administratives paraît-il puisque là il
manque un arrêté donc ces afficheurs ne
sont toujours pas là et on sait on n'est
pas sûr qu'ils soient la nina prochaine
de la prog bien clair que le compteur
d'une qui permet la mise en place de ces
afficheurs là on est dans le domaine
législatif aux législateurs de prendre
cette décision nous aider 10 avec notre
compteur linky à glander
l'administration puisqu'il s'agit d'un
arrêté de
du législateur effectivement surtout si
on permettait je vais passer à la
prochaine saison parce qu'on en est déjà
à plus de la moitié de cette émission
alors autre polémique suscitée par ces
compteurs les coûts des déploiements qui
sont gigantesques du coup puisque je
rappelle les chiffres 13 millions de
compteurs linky déjà déployé en france
35 millions d'ici 2021 on imagine les
coûts que ça implique
alors ce que a dénoncé la cour des
comptes dayan vous l'avez évoqué et vous
aussi
c'est ses coûts répercutés chez les
usagers si j'ai bien compris
alors qu'est ce que vous répondez à
cette prime clair déjà juste avant
rappeler que le compteur il est
indispensable pour la transition
énergétique
sans ce compteur on ne peut pas faire la
transition énergétique c'est quoi la
transition énergétique pour nos
téléspectateurs c'est les bateaux les
panneaux photovoltaïques sur les toits
et vous devenez producteur d'énergie
c'est le véhicule électrique je vais
prendre que deux exemples qui arrivent
tous les constructeurs annoncent
l'arrivée du véhicule électrique de
façon assez massive
il faut qu'on soit capable de gérer
intelligemment ses productions
décentralisées où ces appels de
puissance de véhicules électriques et le
compteur linky le permet ce compteur est
absolument indispensable sur le coût des
compteurs je tiens vraiment à rappeler
que ce conteur et 100% gratuit les
clients qui aujourd'hui pour quasiment
la moitié dans les yvelines ont déjà un
compteur linky n'ont absolument aucun
impact sur leur facture
il m'a dit ce qu'il a dit oui il est
gratuit
les gendarmes et russes ligne jaune à la
coloration de l'unpi sur un an
il ya une facturation différent puisque
après le déploiement on aura donc d un
coût d'environ 15 euros par enfant
donc c'est pourquoi nous nous
nous insistons là-dessus c'est à dire
que le compteur est totalement gratuit
parce que ses aînés 10 qui prend en
charge les coûts de ce crime
l'installation le prix du compteur tout
est pris en compte par une hélice
ces coûts seront complètement couverts
par l'ets bien que ce compteur va
permettre je vais me prendre qu'un seul
exemple nous ne sommes plus amenés à
nous déplacer grâce à ce compteur
puisque les interventions et se font à
distance la relève se fait à distance et
ses gains là vont compenser les coûts du
contenu que nous nous avons chez les
hommes et signale aussi répondre très
rapidement parce qu'on a plus que deux
minutes les nations alors pour revenir
au cou c'est effectivement ce qu'on nous
le discours qu'on nous a tenu au départ
mais c'est pas du tout ce qu'a dit la
cour des comptes
la cour des comptes dit qu'effectivement
il y aura un coût après le déploiement
pour le consommateur qui sera répercuté
sur la facture ou qui sera répercuté
sous forme de manque à gagner si vous
voulez des bénéfices apportés par les
deux groupes en préconisant c'est vrai
que ce soit pris en charge par ce coup
soit accusé par soit effectivement et en
charge par les gains qu'ils sont faits
par un édit savait qu il ne fasse pas de
profit sur sur cette opération
moi je souhaiterais qu'on revienne sur
les problèmes internes dans chez les
consommateurs sur les équipements qui
sont allés rouler en panne que deux
minutes on va devoir le temps
malheureusement d'aborder cet aspect là
je vais plutôt revenir soit on est
vraiment une minute sur
d'une part la question des données
collectées on va avoir une minute alors
sur les données collectées
qu'est ce que vous répondez à une
éventuelle violation des données
personnelles
les données collectées elles ont une
utilité pour le client il faut rappeler
que c'est le client qui est propriétaire
de la donner et que cette donnée va lui
être utile pour maîtriser sa
consommation d'énergie c'est ça
l'essentiel de cette donnée c'est qu'ils
puissent avoir accès à un relevé tous
les jours de sa consommation électrique
voir s'ils le souhaitent toutes les demi
heures c'est ce qu'on appelle la courbe
de charge ou ça permet de visualiser de
façon très graphique ce que vous
consommez et là où vous pourriez faire
des économies d'énergie car c'est
l'intérêt c'était l'intérêt est alors
les dérives possibles qui inquiète
justement une des ses créateurs de
service public et nous respectons
l'ensemble des préconisations de la cnil
donc la commission informatique et
liberté qui précise bien que le client
est propriétaire de s'adonner et que
nous ne transmettons cette donnée à
personne sans l'autorisation explicite
du client ça peut se faire de façon très
simple sur notre site internet où le
client peut nous autoriser ou pas à
diffuser l'information à un tiers qui
leur a choisi et je tiens à rappeler que
nous ne vendons ces données à personne
et que ces données sont sécurisées dans
nos systèmes d'information à la
disposition de nos clients nous vous
faisons confiance à la cnil aux
institutions de ce pays donc il ya
effectivement un chien un chiffrement
qui est effectué entre le compteur et
puis les
les concentrateurs genedis ce qui se
passe après l'annoncé - on aimerait
avoir quelques précisions
effectivement que deviennent ces données
ce qu elles sont stockées pendant
combien de temps et c'est donc c'est
infiniment un petit sujet d'inquiétude
mais qui est à notre niveau moindre que
celui des commandes hier des impacts de
l'installation sur les sur les ménages
que ce soit les installations forcé ou
alors les 10 ou dysfonctionnements qu'on
a pu constater après les installations
ça c'est vraiment notre problème au
niveau local de notre association
consommateurs unis ndt chacun va dire
qu'est ce que vous répondez du coup
enfin j'imagine que vous entendez toutes
ces polémiques
comment réagit aînés dise quelle quelle
solution vous vous restez sur toutes les
positions juste rappeler que donc le
déploiement se passe bien et que la
plupart de nos concitoyens ont déjà le
compteur voilà dans les yvelines en
particulier on est à trois cent mille
compteur déployés donc vous voyez le
déploiement se passe extrêmement bien
sûr un volume de 700 milles à terme dans
l'airé des problèmes excusez moi je sur
l'aspect local
vous avez des retours vous oui on a des
retours de l'installation ainsi mon
collègue de rambouillet était venu vous
aurait expliqué que son compteur à
brûler donc enfin ça ça a été ça a été
réglé par analyse leur directement avec
d'accord avec la direction mais il ya eu
quand même des difficultés à exprimer
ses se comptera donc y est déjà une
réalité pour la plupart des yvelinois et
donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire plus
de relève à distance donc plus besoin de
prendre une demi journée pour attendre
le releveur ça veut dire accès à sa
consommation pour pouvoir maîtriser son
énergie
ça veut dire aussi des baisses de tarifs
concrètes pour les interventions que
nous nous faisons par exemple vous
entrez dans un logement vous
besoin d'une mise en service le tarif
d'ores et déjà dès cette année comme
l'année dernière baisse pour être divisé
par deux à la fin du déploiement du
compteur linky est donc ça c'est du
concret pour nos d'accord pour nous
fuyons mais c'est au signal de 30
secondes qui vous sont à l'essai pour
conclure qu est ce que vous demandez
concrètement qu'est ce que vous attendez
moi je demande qu'à kennedys prenne ses
responsabilités quand une personne a un
problème suite à la mort emplacements de
son compteur que ce problème soit réglé
même s'il s'agit d'une installation
interne voilà cette personne n'a pas
demandé à changer son compteur donc il
faut kennedys prenne ses responsabilités
et qu'on lui dise pas à cette personne
je suis désolé c'est chez vous prenez un
électricien privé j'ai des cas ici je
pourrai soumettre et je souhaite
d'ailleurs qu'on puisse se rencontrer un
peu plus souvent pour qu'on puisse vous
remonter ces cas et que vraiment ces
gens là soient pris en charge
c'était l'art sont connus chez nous ils
sont très rares
très exceptionnel et nous les traitons
au cas par cas avec les clients
concernés quand il a conduit évidemment
d'accord on va conclure là dessus
peut-être de futures rencontres évoqué
par monsieur merci à tous les deux en
tout cas d'avoir accepté notre
invitation c'est la fin de ce sept huit
débats prochaine émission mercredi
prochain d'ici là vous pouvez retrouver
cette émission en replay sur tv8 point
com et sur l'application tv 78 tv
soixante dix huit pour comme excusez moi
merci et très bonne soirée
[Musique]